pour le moment regardez ce maire qui
s'appelle Vincent Paul petit qui qui est
le maire de saport regardez qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez plus de téléphone
dans la rue je suis limite un peu
d'accord avec lui moi moi j'aime bien ce
gars g ver va être d'accord avec lui je
suis sûr oui tu vois g pour une fois on
est d'accord absolument non mais en fait
je suis pas du tout
d'accord c'est après une réflexion
collective entre maire et citoyens que
les habitants de senineport ont voté par
référendum sur la restriction des
portables devant les écoles un arrêté
qui fonctionnerait grâce à la bonne
volonté collectif des citoyens de la
commune après dépouillement 54 % des
participants ont voté pour la charte
contre 46 % le maire publiera un arrêté
dans les prochains jours pour mettre en
œuvre le projet alors oui vous êtes
d'accord mais c'est formidable il y a
pas de sanction c'est de la pédagogie
c'est de l'éducation moi je suis pour
renforcer les pouvoirs du maire il a
envie de faire un effort notamment pour
les enfants c'est une super initiative
pour moi bravo Monsieur le Maire en quoi
c'est un écant pour les enfants de
d'interdire les portabbles un écran
c'est moins d'écran c'est dans la ligée
de
MO non mais notamment la pédagogie c'est
un coup de projecteur pour quelque
chose
pas mais moi j'ai l'impression qu'à
chaque fois ce sont les mères ce sont
les profs qui doivent éduquer les
enfants mais en fait c'est les parents
qui doivent éduquer
lesf ça dans tes
dents tu as des parents c'est à eux te
dire bah là tell moment tu as le droit à
ton portable il y a des parents qui
décident qu'il est 1 heure 2h par jour
30 minutes par jour chacun décide ce
qu'il veut après moi je suis totalement
d'accord avec ce que tu dis oui il faut
un encadrement au niveau du portable et
les enfants mais que ce soit le maire
qui soit obligé de le faire ou que ce
soit un prof ou que ce soit enfin je
trouve on parle dans du délire en fait
il y a des parents pour ça on leur
laisse leur rôle et pu tout se passera
bien il y a deux choses moi je pense
qu'ils veul aller à l'encontre de
quelque chose qui est incontournable
aujourd'hui personne ne peut vivre sans
téléphone en France ton téléphone c'est
ton téléphone ton porte-monnaie ta pièce
d'identité ton moyen de paiement donc
non mais voilà VO donc aujourd'hui quand
on est sans téléphone on est
complètement à poil et il part d'un bon
sentiment cert mais ça risque de créer
des dangers parce que quand on a plus
accès à son téléphone et qu'on peut plus
utiliser son téléphone
salut
Petito merci deaccueillir non avec
plaisir la question la question alors
est-ce que vous aimez le les gens qui
vont dans des soirées du caviard et qui
se disent et qui se disent LFI non la
vraie question c'est vous avez vous
allez prendre un arrêté pour interdire
le téléphone dans la rue est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer gilberdez est
d'accord avec vous c'est la petite
mauvaise nouvelle je vous cache pas
voilà merci à ceux qui sont d'accord
mais c'est pas la question que j'ai
posée alors c'est quoi la question que
j'ai posée qui a été soumise à
référendum dans ma commune ce ce samedi
qui a été adopté favoraablement c'est
est-ce que vous êtes contre les
smartphon dans la fonction smartphone
c'estàdire navigation sur l'Internet ah
mais pas le téléphone d'accordah bravo
on a le droit de téléphoner dans la rue
il y a des urgences il y a des tas de
raisons pour lesqu on a
dro question mais c'est ça c'est c'est
vachement bien il a raison là je suis
d'accord avec lui même le smartphone
c'est vital aujourd'hui moi l'année
dernière alors moi je vous le dis j'ai
fait uneexpériencei l'année dernière je
m'étais coupé complètement j'avais pris
un petit téléphone de il y a 20 ans je
n'ai pas tenu un mois on ne peut plus
vivre sans
smartphone photos c'est pas de notre
faute si tu reçois des photos un vous
demande de scanner des documents quand
vous prenez les transports parfois on
vous demand de scanner un billet non
mais c'est vrai c'est plein de choses
comme ça on vous envoie on vous envoie
des photos on vous envoie par des fiches
contacct le numéro de quelqu'un vous les
recevez je crois que tuas pas compris en
fait en fait tu sais quoi là tu es là tu
es excuse-moi je t'aime beaucoup
chamalou mais là tu Chamalo je t'aime
beaucoup mais là tu es sujet parce que
je vais expliquer ce que dit Monsieur le
Maire si tu as besoin d'un QR code si tu
as besoin de scanner un billet bien sûr
que tu vas avir ton smartphone ce qu'il
dit c'est pas être dans la rue en train
de surfer sur Surre sur les réseaux un
truc comme ça c'est ça que vous dit
alors vous savez vous êtes un adulte je
pense malgré la couleur de votre 12 ans
malgré la couleur de votre
polo pas ta gueule fait pour les
adultes et le problème c'est les enfants
moi je ve prendre qu'un chiffre les
enfants de 10 à 14 ans passent en
moyenne 8 he par jour derrière un écran
en moyenne c'est considérable il y a 10
ans c'était zéro non il y avait la
télévision à la maison excusez-moi mais
là on est passé dans une autre dimension
que font ces enfants pendant 10h ou 8h
sont vous êtes le maire M mais vous
nêtes pas le père
[Applaudissements]
P mais je comprends je comprends ce que
vous voulez dire je comprends vous
soutiz protéger nos enfants et notre
jeunesse mais c'est aussi c'est surtout
et avant tout le rôle des parents et
peut-être pas le vôtre ça jeux dire RA
vous avez en partie raison vous me
permettez je je vais répondre allez-y
monsieur Alley Frédéric Valérie Valérie
Valérie je vous réponds vous savez les
parents on peut les laisser tout seul
face à cette épidémie on peut les
laisser tout seul face à des groupes
mondiaux qui représentent dans leur
capitalisation boursière c'est pas si on
vous parle un peu trois fois le PIP de
la France quand vous prenez les gars
femmes plus TikTok c'est trois fois le
PIP de la France il une puissance
marketing absolument considérable on ne
régulera pas ces gens qui organisent
l'addiction de nos enfants sans des
interdit voilà ma conviction profonde
alors moi je le fais dans ma petite
commune pour faire du bruit et merci de
m'avoir invité par et vous êtes
extrêmement intéressant en plus merci
donc donc voilà voilà la raison mais en
quoi ENI ça va changer quelque chose
chez les gens vous pouvez pas changer au
domiciles des des gens c'est là que la
consommation domicil des gens je leur
donne des recommandations je leur dis
faites attention par exemple un un
enfant qui regarde la télévision même la
télévision le matin avant d'aller à
l'école ne pourra pas être attentif à ce
qui se passe les instituteurs que nous
avons interrogé nous disent aujourd'hui
notre métier est devenu non pas
d'enseigner mais de capter l'attention
des enfants ils sont incapables
d'attention tellement il y a des CR dans
leur vie la chauve-souris après k mais
déjà c'est complètement liberticide et
en plus il y a pas de sanction j'ai cru
comprendre qu' y av pas de sanction si
demain mais si demain vous trouvez un
adolescent dans la rue avec son
téléphone son smartphone vous faites
quoi vous lu saisiss mais non mais
n'importe par
Monuril ont mangé ce cavi samedi soir
lesor qui calme calmei tu comprends pas
mais c'est intéressant la question de la
liberté non mais si Monsieur dit des
choses intéressi je su un me intéressant
oui oui certainement vous avez l'air en
tout cas en tout on se connait pas bien
encore mais je pense que on a des choses
à se dire je su intéressé la liberté
quelle est la liberté d'un enfant qui
passe 8 he par jour derrière un écran
est liberté pour faire quoi pendant 8h
par jour comment où est-ce qu'il les
trouve ces 8h il les trouve sur son
sommeil sur le temps des repas à pas
faire de sport à ne pas lire d'accord et
à ne pas dormir exactement et donc
qu'est-ce qu'il fait pendant C il fait
des choses éducativ il lit des romans
classiques français mais non pas du tout
il passe son temps sur des jeux parfois
violents sur des sites de tous les types
sur des réseaux sociaux qui n'ont aucun
intérêt et qui le rendent extrêmement
addicte essayer d'enlever un téléphone
portable un enfant de 8 ou 10 ans de lui
enlever enever de lui interdire vous
verrez la crise de ner que ça provoque
ça c'est attends attends 2 minutes c'est
bon Adamo là
oui c'est pour ça qu'au final moi je
pense je pense qu'on va être d'accord
c'est un coup de projecteur contre un
nouveau monde qui vous déplaît en fait
c'est ça c'est un coup de projecteur
parce que vous savez qu'en soit ce ne
sera pas faisable la la personne elle
aura son portable dans les mains elle va
pas résister elle va se déconnecter une
heure et elle va y revenir comme tout le
monde parce qu' fait on est tous
addictes comme les enfants les enfants
sont addicts il y a des études qui le
prouvent les enfants qui ont du mal à
apprendre à lire apprendre à écrire à
cause du téléphone les enfants on sait
qu'ils vont mal à cause de ça mais je ne
sais pas mais mais je je félicite votre
coup de projecteur mais en soi il ne
sera pas réalisable on le sait tous
Monsieur le Maire je je ne suis pas sûr
vous savez ce qu'a dit le Premier
ministre hein il s'agit quand même d'un
drame éducatif et de santé publique
c'est les catastrophe éducative et de
santé voilà ce qu'a dit monsieur hatal
donc on peut ne rien faire face à ça on
peut rien faire on peut dire c'est la
société qu'on veut avec une catastrhe
éducative avec un
niau on va jusqu'au bout et on supprime
le portable dans votre ville alors mais
est-ce que vous avez a décidé de bouger
bravo VP est-ce que vous avez conscience
quand même que les smartphones ont
certains avantages pour les enfants qui
permettent de communiquer plus
rapidement que ça les développe aussi
pour le numérique à travailler bien ça
les apprend pas que ça mais par exemple
WhatsApp et ce ça fac ça peut faciliter
la communication et quand on vous écoute
on a l'imession effectiv voule er et
revenir à l'ancien temps où les enfants
jouent avec des billes avec des ocelet
mais ça on le fera plus jamais plus
jamaisou Bou c'est tellement loin de ce
que je veux faire parce que je vais vous
expliqu je une petite anecdote voilà ce
qu'on
faire dans la charte que j'ai soumise et
qui était accepté par mes mes
administrés 54 % donc il a eu un débat
et un débat comme
celui-là pendant 6 mois on l'a eu il y a
20 % des gens qui sont venus voter c'est
tro fois plus qu'à Paris tant
mieux dire déjà pas mal et donc on va
offrir aux enfants qui passent un 6e en
6e un téléphone à touche avec ne touches
où ils pourront téléphoner 331 oui mais
il manque le Z voulez je sais pas quel
est le jeux pas faire la publicité avec
ils pourront téléphoner ils pourront
envoyer des SMS ils pourront même
écouter de la musique d'accord et faire
des photos touches et ça on l'offrira
aux enfants contre l'engagement des
parents qui n'auront pas de smartphone
jusqu'à 15 ans voà des choses très
concrètes et ça ça suffit pour les
enfants touch tous les parents me disent
ve on veut les joindre évidemment je
comprends ce problème de sécurité je
comprends t ces sujets tout le reste n'a
aucun intérêt pour les enfants on peut
leur dire passer votre temps sur des
jeux sur des jeux en réseau et cetera
hyper violent faut voir ce qu'il
voit réseau regarder ce qu'il voit sur
les réseaux alors juste il y a ne9
touches 10
peut-êtreou il manque le zé ou le 9 une
connerie c'estd que le gars qui a un
numéro avec un U non tu peux pas t'aeler
frère je ve bien je veux bien mais je ne
peux pas t'appeler je n'ai pas
le merci Monsieur le Maire VP Vincent
Paul petit merci d'avoir été avec nous
au moins il bouge lui au moins au MOS il
bouge voilà bravo à vous et il a eu plus
de votes que
anidalg merci merci Vincent Paul petit
merci d'avoir été
là